best thing to eat on a golf course  peanut butter and banana sandwich I tend  to lose weight when I play every time I  play I lose three to four pounds per  tournament best celebrity foursome that  you've ever played around with Schmaltz  and Clavin and Maddox and they're all  picture with the Braves that was epic I  shot 62-63 and lost money best  professional athlete non-golfer they you  know see their small sore Romo they both  can play root golf really well what's  the funniest thing a fan has ever said  to you on a golf course a female to ask  me to sign something then the security  guard told her to put that away and  nothing happened dream celebrity  foursome that you'd want to play around  it wouldn't be a foursome it'd be my dad  myself and Charlie